welcome back to the show on the day of
president elect Donald Trump's
inauguration we'll answer some audience
questions will uh I don't know about
keeping it light but we'll do some non
Trump questions just because you know I
think there's a little bit of saturation
for people going on I think that's the
happy medium there yeah something like
that
first question is from Adria who says
hey guys when is censoring warranted in
news stories whether it's graphic images
words or disturbing details you know
sometimes it's useful to have very very
specific guidelines for what is or is
not allowed on a particular forum or
venue and other times it's best to say
you know it when you see it and
different countries are known to have
different standards in terms of what's
allowed in the news when you look at
European news about war it's much more
common that you have violent and graphic
videos which arguably help to connect
people with the real horrifying nature
of war and armed conflict the counter to
that and we tend to adhere more to this
in the United States is you know there's
kids watching the news and we don't want
to expose young children necessarily to
graphic or violent images that maybe
their parents don't want them to see or
whatever is the case now you know that
I've made the case many times that when
it comes to censorship of fiction shows
right so whether it's nudity or swearing
or whatever in Argentina where I was
born
swearing and nudity on TV I mean I'm not
talking about porn but swearing and
nudity is not really considered a big
deal right nobody's worried about it's
gonna ruin children's lives if they see
a breast or maybe hear an f-bomb or
whatever the case may go back to our
puritanical society absolutely does here
in the United States and I'm sort of
fine with that and I've said it makes no
sense at all for the government to be
wasting time money and resources
enforcing that type of thing when it
comes to censorship in news stories I
think it's much more difficult to say I
am for telling the whole story but then
you get really specific issues like okay
do you show a picture of a perpetrator
in a terrorist attack do you not show
the picture but use their name do you
not even use their name
any any information that you give about
them is going to say hey if you do
something terrible you will be famous
and it could in some way encourage other
people to commit acts of violence I
believe that to the extent that graphic
images words or details help us to be
better informed about the context
implications and consequences of
whatever the news story is I say include
them for example a counter example would
be if you have a story about a horrible
death in a car accident for example are
you really adding to the story by
showing autopsy pictures of the dead
person's body I don't think that you are
I mean I think it's pretty easy to get a
sense of how horrific a car accident can
be from the fact that you're reporting
someone died and you're showing the
mangled car and you're showing the
family members of the victim crying or
whatever I don't know that we're gaining
much by showing autopsy pictures that's
one example on the other hand I think
that if there has been a terrorist
attack that it's perfectly fine to show
again you can decide what level of
detail you want to zoom in on but the
fact that if there was a terrorist
attack in an airport there are dead
bodies on the ground I'm ok with that I
think that does contextualize the real
horrors of the environment where the
attack took place I mean I think it
really depends on the scenario the
context and it differs each scenario to
the next yeah I think there are
definitely reasons why you would want to
censor things like for example if there
was a victim of some major crash or
catastrophe or something I could see
that the victim and their family may not
want to have that information and those
images released to the public I'm
talking about like personal details yeah
yeah I think because those are the
victims and aren't the perpetrators I
think they have every right to have
their identity sealed
how about words with words I'm Way more
loose I mean I I think it's there are
very few situations where I would
advocate the self-censorship of words
when it comes to explaining what
happened in a news story for me it's
more about decisions on graphic videos
and pictures yeah especially with words
that the word that comes to my mind is
the n-word because if you're quoting
someone else using that in context I
think
most news reporters are weary of wording
them of quoting them verbatim yeah
that's a very tricky thing I I think
that that's interesting I mean I tend to
like I don't use the n-word personally
but I don't know that we do remoting
someone else yeah I don't even know that
we have necessarily a policy on the show
but generally speaking like if we have a
video or a quote from someone else we'll
will use the full n-word I think that's
generally the policy and again our
decisions are more based on there are
certain words which our broadcast
affiliates cannot air because they will
get fined by the FCC
we obviously censor those but beyond
that we tend not to censor yeah and then
when it comes to images and video clips
we also yeah we have this debate every
time one comes up because there was an
assassination of one of those Russian
official yeah a few weeks ago right and
we had this we really just opened it up
to the audience over whether or not we
should show it show the video yeah yeah
um one other thought on this there are
some people who will hear me saying
David oh my god Davey you're such a
special snowflake trigger warnings safe
space clown [ __ ] or whatever right the
truth is that this isn't about being a
special snowflake or being triggered or
whatever it's about do we need to show
anything that we can find simply for the
sake of being salacious and inflammatory
and if it leads it bleeds type of thing
and so for me the question is not am I
trying to protect people it's a my
crafting a story that is fully
informative and do I need to go out of
my way to include graphic images if they
don't actually add to the telling of the
story that's my standard I agree with
that policy yeah you shouldn't go out of
your way to include information that's
not necessary or pertinent to the story
but if everyone else is reporting in the
same way I think you should go along
with that